[Music]
sarah kubrick is a writer and
existential psychotherapist
she writes a weekly column for usa today
but online she is the millennial
therapist
she has a wonderful perspective on
authenticity self love acceptance and
responsibility and in this time of high
stress high anxiety
i wanted to talk to her more about how
we can protect our mental health
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
sarah you call yourself an existential
therapist an existential psychotherapist
i understand what those words mean but
you put them together so i have to ask
what exactly
is an existential therapist so an
existential therapist is someone who
helps people figure out their meaning in
life and helps them figure out who they
are so how long have you been doing this
the therapy i mean including training
probably like eight years
on my own probably like four and have
you noticed a change
in the questions people are asking
or the challenge that they're facing in
the past eight years
absolutely i mean it's really difficult
for me to say it's
because society is
it could also be that my demographic is
changing as well but i i would argue
that especially with covet
everyone became a bit more existential i
feel like there was an existential
crisis overall so especially in 2020
people started to ask the question what
for i think a lot of people um
mistook kind of their roles or their
success as their identity
and when that was stripped away during
covid
they all went okay but who am i now that
i can't go into my office and so i think
priorities shifted i think
purpose became um
something that was on their radar and i
think for all of them they realized that
money couldn't help them if that makes
sense they were still as miserable
they couldn't buy their way out of this
one they couldn't buy their way out of
this one and i think it it really
shifted their priorities and do you
think it's sticky because you know when
you're in crisis it's like being in a
troubled relationship you fantasize
about the future and the grass is always
greener but as soon as it's over
back to the way things were sometimes
it's sticky and i'm curious if you think
once they have that direction that
they're going to completely follow that
direction or once the world goes back to
semi-normal-ish that it'll all be
forgotten until the next crisis i think
it's probably the latter
any
oh good you're cynical like me i'm super
cynical i'd like to think
a big awakening for people and i just
don't think that's true for everybody um
i think that humans
have the tendency to gravitate towards
the familiar the comfortable and you
changing your life because you had an
epiphany usually doesn't fall into that
category right living an authentic life
takes a lot of work and intention and
many many decisions that people don't
want to make
um so i i think it's going to be
really hard especially because although
people are changing their their
priorities or finding their meaning
for most of them it's not actually
rooted in who they are most of them
don't know who they are and so i think
when
those two are disconnected you're more
likely to not follow through
i mean i can't help but ask about the
great resignation as you say that you
know so many people are saying this is
this is not what i want this is not for
me i'm going to pursue my dreams
or
i know my value i know my worth i'm out
of here
pursuing a dream
as you said takes a lot of work and a
lot of difficult decisions
and so i'm curious based on the people
you're talking to if they're part of
this
a what the great resignation means and
if it's less sticky than we would both
like it to be then what are the
repercussions over the next year or two
i feel like
there are a lot of studies that show
the impact has had on our mental health
because of the prolonged chronic state
of the unknown
and how difficult that is for us so our
coping mechanisms that often worked
don't
and so the freeze flight fight
isn't you can't do that for two years
straight and so we're noticing a decline
in mental health
maybe people are having these moments of
i'm gonna change my life and i've
survived this and
now i'm going to embrace the unknown
i would also suggest that it's already a
[ __ ] show i feel like if you fail now
you're not the only one failing
i feel like there is just this
safety blanket there
maybe if you quit your job now when
everyone else is quitting their job or
people are being laid off and then you
don't succeed you're just one of the
people that didn't succeed but you
didn't do that five years ago when
everyone wanted stability and that was
something that was really obtainable for
the masses i think it's also an excuse
for a large amount of people to do it
because they're not happy or they don't
want to put in the work and they think
the solution is to do something
different rather than to work harder
um and so you know and they're going to
find that out once they
they switch their career track and don't
succeed and i'm not saying that's for
everybody
i preface this with being a bit cynical
but i think when i hear you talking
about it when i think of my own
experiences in community that's kind of
what comes to mind okay so i know you're
the millennial therapist because you're
a millennial not because you necessarily
only talk to millennials right but let's
be honest millennials love you
as you're talking about
you know they're doing it now because it
feels like the stakes are lower
and
there may be a shock later when they
realize there's actually a lot of work
to do in whatever this new thing they
want to do is
sounds eerily like some of the
complaints levied against the millennial
generation in the past
discuss
[Laughter]
look i don't think the millennials are
entitled or lazy
across the board i actually don't think
that's true at all i think millennials
work really freaking hard and i think
what we've accomplished as a generation
is quite remarkable we've changed
society
i genuinely believe that
do i think we always have the tools to
cope with the society we've created no
yeah i think there's so much pressure
on us in any really job at this point
that it's okay if you're failing to like
there is grace there for me because now
it's not enough that you just have a job
but it has to be a really cool job that
also your friends kind of want it also
has to be super meaningful but you also
need to be making millions and you also
need to be an activist in some way and
you also and also and also and so the
stakes are just so high and i think
we have set unrealistic expectations and
so people walking away
part of it makes sense and part of it
could be for their own mental health and
part of it could be just that we don't
have the tools to stick it out what are
some of those tools that you think are
lacking so millennials
i think
from my work at least again i speak for
that i cannot no no of course we
understand no you're making
generalizations based on observation and
of course it doesn't apply to everybody
of course
cool okay nice disclaimer i think that
we are really not in touch with
ourselves i think there's so much
stimulation that comes from the outside
there's so many expectations
need for validation all the stuff that
was present before but i think the
social media enhanced it
i think that scrolling through your
phone is a form of escapism of calming
down of coping
i don't think we sit there and go oh my
god i'm uncomfortable so i'm gonna check
in with myself and take a deep breath
we're like
i'm feeling something so i'm gonna grab
my phone i'm peeing so i'm gonna grab my
phone and there's absolutely no moment
of solitude and reflection
unless you're really intentional about
it just because
it's not really constructed to be that
way anymore and so
what like now you even have little
commercials on buses and like little tvs
in in cabs like you're being told
something all the time and so we're not
listening to ourselves and so i think
that millennials don't have the tools
necessarily to
figure out how they're feeling it's
really as basic as you know some of my
clients in the first couple sessions
can't
identify an emotion
that they're experiencing i also think
another tool that really translates to
workspaces is boundaries
i don't think you know millennials know
how to set boundaries necessarily
because we want it all and we want it
now and there's something really cool
about that and motivational and then
there's also something super unrealistic
and so i think those two tools just like
translate to us doing poorly in any
context not just work give me an example
of the inability to set a boundary
professionally or personally and how it
backfires for example i
won't
answer emails after 8 pm
and then you go i feel pressure to do
work or
fulfill this task after 8 pm although
you know that you're too tired and
you're not focused and then you don't
perform super well and then he backfires
in two ways one you betrayed yourself
you didn't take care of yourself your
mental health might suffer and then the
second is your performance sucked
and so there's really no
no wind there and i think we just want
to please
not realizing that actually boundaries
can preserve some of those relationships
including work relationships so you're
advocating i will not check an email
after 8 pm depending on your job yeah
like set some parameters that make sense
for your job yeah in particular i concur
i like when
when we set boundaries
and i like when my team like we we force
our team to set boundaries
you know like we we don't want people
working on the weekends but we always
add unless there's a real need to
like there are but i but i think that's
lost you know in my experience with some
people that little caveat that there's
always exceptions to these policies
rather than rules
they were always extenuating
circumstances
and that little nuance which i think is
very very important
is lost as an employer or just as a
friend or just as somebody in society or
as an observer
the understanding between a rigid
boundary and a flexible boundary that
those distinctions seem to be fuzzy
today
super fuzzy and i think that the whole
mental health movement
instagram therapy quote-unquote has
maybe made that worse yeah
i think that people just didn't know
what boundaries were and i'm so glad
that we are talking about the concept of
boundaries
but i think sometimes people take
okay i'll give you an example
i have had a friend
text me and go i just had a huge
argument
with a family member about boundaries
and they sent me your post to prove
their point and then i had to go and
find another post to explain how
actually i was right and so they were
exchanging my posts during a fight
wow bless you know like this is not what
my content is for
please don't do this whatever but it
really got me thinking of how people
they see what they want to see they take
what they want to take right so
especially they've been abused or
or misused or mistreated um they're more
likely to overcorrect and have super
strict boundaries
and so that's just process of learning
you hope that those people will then
eventually go fall into the flexible
boundaries so i understand but i think
because there is education and because
as therapists were always preaching
boundaries the nuance might be lost
sometimes um and people might be super
extreme and then of course you're going
to get fired of course you're going to
be a terrible worker of course you're
not going to be able to have a healthy
relationship because they're completely
closed off and they're using them more
as a form of isolation and distance than
understanding and connection right
yes
and then sets off this cycle
of
i'm struggling i lack the coping
mechanisms to deal with stress or
uncertainty
i read i get my therapy from instagram
yeah you shouldn't it's not therapy
right somebody sent me a meme i throw a
thing on instagram it all made sense to
me that's the solution to my problem i
implement the thing
it didn't work i'm more insecure more
uncertain the vicious cycle continues
and then we end up with clinical
anxieties and depressions or worse and
and so to your point which i find so
interesting which is there's an
education here and that education has to
come from
some talking to someone like you talking
you know to someone like you not just
reading
a book or an article or a meme or a post
and saying i've got it
and i struggle with it because there are
people who i care about and love who i
want to be there for but the desire to
have engage in that difficult discussion
is not there yeah oh my gosh
yeah the whole point on my instagram too
wasn't initially to necessarily educate
it was to get people curious about
themselves yeah
it is not the bible of psychology it is
not
you know the final word it's meant to
evoke or even sometimes provoke things
yeah yeah yeah
and then it's up to you to you know
figure it out like sometimes they'll get
comments and people will be like
well how do i deal with it or you didn't
give us a solution it's like
well i'm not actually here to give you
the solution it's part of your own
personal experience you need to tell me
what you want to do next now that you're
aware of the fact that these things
resonate with you yeah and i think we
all want those quick answers and that's
something i try really hard not to offer
because the point is for me yes to raise
awareness but really is for you to start
having inner dialogue not for me to tell
you what to do because then we're losing
a really important skill
which i think is ultimately the most
important skill which is self-awareness
changing tax on you where are you right
now i am in amsterdam right now so where
do you consider home i just
technically
have
become based in australia as of 2020 but
i'm a canadian citizen so i'm kind of
straddling canada and australia at the
moment and what is the reason for your
nomadic lifestyle i honestly think you
had something to do just with my
upbringing and being an immigrant and
all that good stuff and always moving as
a child
but i genuinely enjoy it i started
in my mid-20s
as a way to work on myself find myself
you know
all the stereotypes um but he actually
worked um and it was a really profound
experience for me i got to live in in
countries and within cultures that i
never thought i would
and then i started to be
curious what did you discover about
yourself
oh um i think when everything changes
constantly it forces you to find
yourself real quick
because you're the only constant and i
think when we're in routine it's so easy
to blame other people
or contexts
and i think when you're the only common
denominator you're like oh [ __ ] it's me
oh that's on me and so it was really it
was an awakening journey i think also
living in cultures that are not super
easy for women was difficult for me but
i think it also empowered me to think
about
what is being a woman and what does that
mean for me and so there's a ton of
stuff facing my own you know childhood
trauma going back to serbia
um
realizing the trauma doesn't define you
and it's something that can build
resilience and so i think there was just
an endless stream of things that i
learned in each place that i went to
were you in serbia and yugoslavia when
it was no longer becoming yugoslavia
were you there for the for the war
i was there um for the war 91 that was
in bosnia um actually i was born in
bosnia so that
genocide occurred uh during that time
when my family flew to
nowadays serbia um and then the kosovo
war occurred and then we immigrated to
canada so i got to kind of experience
both of those how long were you in this
high stress environment um it depends
what you define as high stress
environment i still feel high stress
environment when i go there it's it's
such an intense atmosphere still it's
such a traumatic atmosphere i really
don't know how to like you feel
depressed after being there for a couple
months
we were there
a year after the war ended in kosovo
yeah and then we left i think high
stress i was probably only there for
about two months in serbia during the
bombings and then we escaped to
bosnia and that was interesting because
we tried to do it separately i was like
fine and so when you talk about you talk
about kovid that we can't be on this
fight-or-flight response for an
extenuating period of time
i think about my grandmother my
grandfather
my grandfather was off to war in the
second world war but my grandmother was
back in london
living through the blitz
i remember the beginning of covid you
know the panic that we all felt what
gave me calm was thinking of my
grandmother through the blitz which is
if we stay at home we were 100 safe and
my grandmother like so many during the
blitz they went to work every day and a
building that was there yesterday is not
there today and you were safe nowhere at
any time i thought about that that she
got through that and was still strong
through her whole life that if she could
get through that
man i could get through this
and i have a great aunt that lived
through the holocaust and she was a rock
uh and her husband wasn't and she said
if you went through something like that
you came out of it only one of two ways
you came out of it stronger or you came
out of it broken
that was it agreed
yeah
absolutely and it was interesting to
watch my family doing their pandemic
they were so chill yeah
like there was panic there was so much
panic and they were just like we're so
blessed we have food it's okay we are at
home we're together and it wasn't like
that forced positivity
be grateful for what you have which you
know has its place but it really wasn't
forced
they were genuinely just grateful um and
that was interesting to see that for
many people covet was the worst thing
they've ever experienced or the biggest
threat they've ever that was ever
imposed on them and for people that it
wasn't i think kobit was slightly less
traumatizing um
if i if i can use that word and just
looking at my family i mean they did
afford food definitely were one of those
people and i think that was more of a
trauma response honestly just because
we've been in situations where we just
didn't have food um but other than that
they were just so happy they went on
their one hour nature walks and it was
really interesting to see that division
of people that have lived through things
and this was just another thing they
knew that they were capable of surviving
and then individuals that felt really
threatened existentially threatened for
the very first time which raises a very
interesting question because for quite a
long time and i don't mean this
generation mean like millennials or
anything like that but this generation
meaning the time we're living in it's
been pretty cushy the cold war's
gone
and then since the fall of the berlin
wall like
nobody's really felt much existential
threat of anything
so much so that we seem to be looking
for it that we seem to be looking to
find meaning in ourselves by
anointing someone else the existential
threat whether it's political divide or
or others but the point is it's pretty
soft
and goes to your point which is
lack of experience lack of difficulty
lack of stress you know you don't
develop the skill set to deal with it
and i wonder if we flash forward 10 or
20 years and this is the thing i'm so
curious about which of course there's no
way to know but to wait like those who
live through the second world war the
great depression for the rest of their
lives reused every jam jar and saved
every piece of tin foil because they
lived through rations
i'm so curious the 10 and 12 and 13 and
14 year olds during covid
are they going to be like really good at
reading people's eyes because they
haven't seen the rest of their faces
are they going to be like afraid to
shake people's hands like what quirks
are their grandkids going to make fun of
them for that were formed right now
i just think it's kind of valuable to
have a little trauma in your life now
and then i'm not talking about
existential trauma but to have a little
difficulty seems like a good thing no
well i was just gonna say i think
there's a difference between getting
skills to cope with stress
and experiencing severe trauma yes i
mean i i wouldn't say that every
generation or everyone benefits from
living through severe trauma yes you
know i wouldn't go as far um
difficult
difficulty difficulty yeah you know a
professor of mine said there's no change
without tension or difficulty and i
genuinely believe that as well i i think
you need to learn
and i think difficulty why millennials
get so much [ __ ] with me defending them
is that the difficulties they're
experiencing are not as valued as the
difficulty that our parents have
experienced so we go well you didn't
live through a war
so calm down and get some resilience but
in reality
i think the psychological
warfare of social media and everything
they have to put up with
could be just as severe it's just very
very different so i i do think that
we have some very tough lessons to learn
as millennials especially gen zetters
which i think
in my personal opinion i'm the most
cared for yeah i'll try that's gen z for
those who aren't canadian or english oh
yeah sorry sorry i'll translate for you
it's fine thank you but here's the
twisted irony right and i think you're
on to something which is that there is
real difficulty and little t trauma that
people are experiencing with the social
media wars and the ghostings and the
taking your opinions out publicly and
humiliating people and preserving you
know when i tripped over in the
cafeteria and made a fool of myself
everybody laughed at me made fun of me
for the day and it was over now
someone's going to video it it's going
to be on youtube for the rest of my life
or worse text it to everybody in some
group chat and i won't ever be able to
let go like i understand
those those difficulties and those
little t traumas or sometimes those lead
to big t traumas and the irony
here is those that went through war went
through it together physically actually
as you know
when we go through shared hardship it
produces oxytocin which actually
strengthens relationships
and here you have people going through
these difficulties in these little tea
traumas alone
and
where i struggle and i have huge empathy
is the lack of skill set to ask for help
and even going inside and finding
yourself and asking yourself questions i
still think requires help
it could be a friend it could be a
therapist it could be a loved one a
family member but to try and do this
thing called life alone
is madness life is way too difficult
none of us are strong enough or smart
enough
especially if you're in pain the lack of
clarity and objectivity when when you're
in it
and so there's a great irony which is
the generation that is suffering from
difficulty and trauma because of the
pressures that they face
alone connected to their telephones or
their social media is exaggerating
their need to ask for help which
literally is missing i think that's part
of the expectation is that you will do
it on your own this is the construct
that we have that we're so incredibly
independent
that
we don't we don't need what everyone
else needed and now we're
self-sufficient then
i have no idea where this narrative came
from but it's so prevalent that now when
we can't do it alone which we absolutely
cannot like we have a basic human need
for connection
um
then we feel like a failure and there's
shame for doing something that's as
natural as breathing essentially
and so that's
it's it's a big lose-lose and we also
have this assumption that because we're
on social media we're connecting
there's a difference between being
noticed and being generally acknowledged
uh you know someone liking something of
yours and someone actually validating
you and seeing you and appreciating you
for who you are i think there's just
this lack of actual genuine connection
and
lack of acknowledgement of who we are as
people and so then that intensifies the
loneliness because it doesn't matter if
you have a big social media following i
know a ton of influencers almost
committed suicide it's not about that
you're still alone because you're not
genuinely connecting and i think
millennials have confused connection
with social media because it's a
platform where we connect i think your
distinctions are so good noticed but not
acknowledged
liked but not validated that we've
confused those terms uh confused the
meaning
are the themes that we're talking about
consistent around the world or is this a
very ethnocentric point of view
i think loneliness is a really prevalent
one almost everywhere i've traveled just
because we talked about it and i think
the identity crisis is huge it's not
just the north american thing i think
when i lived in the middle east a lot of
people
you know were educated maybe in london
or
you know went to university in new york
and then they came back and then they
didn't feel like they fit or they're so
exposed to
media in hollywood and whatever and so
now they kind of want to integrate that
into their society but it's not working
and they feel alone and they feel
misunderstood and they're not connecting
what do you recommend
is a healthy way
to interact with social media know why
you're on it why are you posting why are
you looking i mean this is a
conversation i had with myself
um are you posting a picture because you
want people to
make you feel good that day are you
posting a picture because you want to
share an experience that you enjoyed
is it because you want people to
genuinely see you is it because you want
people to see
this persona of you like what is your
intention with every post
there's times when you know i no one
likes my post and i'm like damn it i
really like this post why don't people
like it and at the start it used to
really upset me because i'm like what is
this you know and then i got to go okay
why are you posting this is this
something that you think might be of
value to two people and if it is
is that fulfilling the mission of this
post and it's like yeah it is i want to
communicate this i think this is
meaningful and this is how i'm
experiencing the world so this is just
what i'm sharing right and i'm not
expecting anything back and so setting
those boundaries with yourself is so
important when you outsource your
self-love and self-acceptance and
self-validation to other people then
you're in trouble that's well put can
you tell me an early specific happy
childhood memory it was during the war
ironically um we escaped to bosnia just
my siblings my parents stayed in serbia
because they had to
and i was on my grandpa's farm and there
was a little forest and
my brother made me a tree house actually
we made it together so
every day we would go and bring the
supplies and cut the wood and we would
make this like little tree house
together and then he would teach me how
to sword fight um and so i just got to
spend so much time with my brother and i
think um he made it a really special
time even though if you think about it
rationally was probably one of the most
stressful times for the adults
you know what i've learned from this
whole conversation with you
that you have devoted your life to
helping people build a tree house
where they can find safety
and you'll teach them how to sword fight
and you'll do the work with them but
they still have to do the work with you
like you're not going to build it for
them they have they have to gather wood
as well
but your role in life is to help people
build the treehouse that they can live
in and feel safe i love that that really
deeply resonates i mean i didn't think
of a cool analogy like that before but
that does deeply resonate with me thank
you sarah kubrick for helping us think
and for being so willing to help us
build a treehouse in which we can feel
safe
[Music]
if you're interested in learning more
about sarah and her work
follow her on instagram
at
millennial therapist
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other